meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
guten tag wie immer war einer der
hauptthemen heute corona in der
bayrischen kabinettsitzung insbesondere
mit blick auf die feiertage und der
jetzt sind einige stunden statt für den
minister sind konferenz für die weitere
planung im grunde genommen haben wir
gemischte gefühle der gute ansatz ist
die korona zahlen in bayern sinken
weiter und zwar auch entgegen dem
bundestrend wo sie es leicht wieder nach
oben entwickelt hat sinken die zahlen in
bayern weiter wir haben heute entstand
von 276 inzidenz das ist platz zehn wir
liegen sogar hinter den ländern die im
impfen scheinbar viel höhere quoten
haben insbesonders norddeutschland das
sind sehr positive signal dieses
positive signal bedeutet zum einen mal
dass die gesamten maßnahmen gewirkt
haben es gab noch vor einigen wochen da
auch sehr kritik an bayern über sind die
maßnahmen angemessen reichen die man
kann sagen ja das gesamte
maßnahmenkatalog des freistaats bayern
in dieser schwierigen kroner zeit hat
glaube ich gewirkt und deswegen
herzliches dankeschön an die bevölkerung
und auch all diejenigen die diese
maßnahme beschwert sein es hat sich
gelohnt auch die belastungen in
krankenhäusern geht leicht zurück die
bettenzahl entspannt sich leicht und
insofern kann man sagen ist das eine
positive entwicklung was das management
bei data betrifft man kann schon sagen
die delta entwicklung hat sich in bayern
gut dargestellt und die maßnahmen wirken
und alles was da von uns auf den weg
gebracht ist war zielführend auch das
impfen läuft gut
beim boosten kombi goran wir haben fast
jeden tag um die 200.000 booster
impfungen in bayern und an einmal zur
zahl zu setzen weil ich am wochenende
wieder demonstrationen waren wo liegt
die mehrheit wenn 10.000 demonstrieren
und sich zeitlich 50.000 an am sonntag
boostern lassen dann zeigt das relativ
eindeutig wie auch die demokratische
verteilung sozusagen ist die bayern
lassen sich im von postern und das finde
ich sehr positiv das heißt wir können
jetzt auch was diese woche betrifft und
weihnachten betrifft eigentlich
zuversichtlich auf das weihnachtsfest
schauen denn zu weihnachten selber wird
es keine einschränkungen geben man kann
aufgrund der jeweiligen kronach
situation auch in den landkreisen in
bayern werden einige die früher hot
spots über 1000 waren und liegen jetzt
unter dem bundesdurchschnitt sind alles
positive zahlen das muss man einfach so
sehen und deswegen kann man weihnachten
doch feiern das ist der positive ansatz
und die sorge bleibt aber was passiert
mit nikon wie entwickelt sich omikron zu
was passiert dann scheinbar scheint ist
keine welt ist eine wand zu sein die wir
klaus holetschek die da auf bayern bzw
deutschland zukommt wahrscheinlich in
anderen teilen eher als bei uns oder
schneller als bei uns und der
expertenrat ist der relativ eindeutig
die auf diese extreme herausforderung
durch omikron hinweist auch omikron ist
bereits da in bayern wir haben fälle
nachgewiesen aber wir haben noch kein
exponentielles wachstum in bayern beiden
vorhandene mikrowelle jedenfalls ist es
nicht erkennbarer lässt sich das auch
absehen trotzdem gilt der grundsatz
oberste vorsicht oberste vorsicht bleibt
der grundsatz insbesondere bei der
zugrundelegung der expertenmeinung
oberste vorsicht heißt auch dass man
nicht der welle hinterher laufen darf
und dass man auch nicht unbedacht
hineinstolpern darf sondern man muss das
gesamte ausmaß und die maßnahmen die
notwendig sind und darauf zu reagieren
in breite und gänse diskutieren und
nicht einzelne kleine aspekte zu nehmen
deswegen ist auch nicht eine mpk die
lösung sondern es muss ein breiter
ansatz sein die bisherige beschluss der
vorliegt glaube ich deckt die dimension
einer möglichen herausforderung nur
bedingt ab vorsicht ja aber auch keine
hektik oder panik
dafür sind nach wie vor viele fragen
ungeklärt
es erscheint er sozusagen ist die
verläufe milder sind es gibt immer noch
keine exakte aussage klaus holetschek
ist die gefährdung für kinder und
jugendliche schwieriger und man kann
auch nicht exakt vorhersagen wie die
belastung ist für die krankenhäuser das
sind bleibt man beim beim thema vorsicht
aber es muss angemessen sein der heutige
beschlussvorlage der mpk bietet wohl
keine grundlegende veränderung für
bayern darum haben wir uns auch schon
verständigt im kabinett dass wir das was
da wohl kommt an anpassen bei uns machen
aber im grunde genommen kann man sagen
wir das bayerische corona protokoll
weitgehend national
übernommen von clubs discos fußball und
anderen großveranstaltungen also alle
dinge die wir haben mehr masken pflicht
also prinzip wird das übernommen ob das
am ende reicht diese maßnahmen ist
deswegen unklar weil die meisten
bundesländer haben keine möglichkeit
einer rechtlichen absicherung von
hotspots wir haben durch die damalige
entscheidungen die hotspots vor dem
neuen infektionsschutzgesetz zu machen
haben wir eigentlich ein relativ weit
reichendes instrumentarium um im fall
der fälle auch reagieren zu können und
zwar sehr schnell auch das heißt wir
haben das in national haben das die
meisten bundesländer nicht wir haben es
nicht deswegen braucht es um omikron
anzugehen auch keine regionale strategie
und auch kein verweis und auch keine
delegation an vor ort sondern es braucht
eine national einheitliche rahmen und
dieser muss jetzt heute nochmal
diskutiert werden ich glaube die
entscheidende frage ist einfach die
epidemische notlage wiederherzustellen
dies ist der eigentliche pferdefuß an
der gesamten und der eigentliche grund
und kardinalsfehler den die neue
bundesregierung die ampel eigentlich
gemacht hat denn nur dieser herstellung
der epidemische notlage gibt die
möglichkeit rasch und im zweifelsfall
notwendig zu reagieren alles andere ist
so ein rumgeeiere die am ende
möglicherweise nicht ausreicht deswegen
sollte man das als nationalen ansatz so
schnell wie möglich herstellen
gesetzgeberisch ist das eine das zweites
wichtig ist eine absolute gewähren
sicherheit dass der impfstoff
funktioniert machen wir doch gerne mal
pro jahr zukommen wir wären über die
impfstoffversorgung bayern reden wenn
jetzt wir hören auch empfehlungen kommen
könnten von der stiko das hört man so
ist noch nicht bestätigt dass boost dann
schneller sein schon nach drei monaten
wird sich der impf druck noch einmal
deutlich erhöhen deswegen ist wichtig
dass der arbeiten wir daran die imker
und arztpraxen wie es nur irgendwie geht
geöffnet bleiben ich bin übrigens auch
dafür dass mit impfzentren das ganze
nächste jahr fortführen weil wir nämlich
nach dem ganzen bus denn jetzt den
verschiedenen wellen des boosters auch
die neue nikon im stoff impfung dann zu
verknüpfen und insofern wird es keine
100 fahren von 15 der nächsten jahr mehr
geben weil wir einfach diese kapazität
auch zusätzlich brauchen wichtig ist
dass jetzt die impfstoffe wirklich
versorgung gewährleistet ist da kein
schauspiel drum ist wann wo wie viel
sondern es muss eine gewährleistung
sicherheit da sein wichtig ist auch das
möglichst schnell der sogenannte tod im
stoff nummer tax auch bei der auf
europäischer ebene zugelassen wird auch
besorgt wird und auch in die
vergütungsstruktur eingefügt ich halte
ich für ganz wichtig dass wir so rasch
wie möglich auch alternative impfstoffe
einführen denn jedes impfen hilft auch
wenn wir jetzt wissen dass boostern die
entscheidende herausforderung ist ist es
wichtig immer mehr leute dazu zu bringen
sich impfen zu lassen und was immer noch
fehlt es gibt nach wie vor keine genaue
struktur waren apotheken sich beteiligen
können wenn das boostern klappen soll
dann brauchen wir auch mehr stellen als
nur impfzentren und arztpraxen
ebenso unklar was heute geklärt wer muss
es wie es der rechtsstatus der genesenen
und wann ist bei genesenen booster
notwendig auch david bislang überhaupt
keine aussage getroffen wir glauben ist
es wichtig ist denn wir haben jetzt auch
gerade in bayern
aufgrund der vierten welle dw jetzt sehr
viele menschen die jetzt wieder gesund
sind beziehungsweise genesen sind aber
die sich auch die frage stellen was wird
jetzt da es gibt nach wie vor keine
entsprechende empfehlung durch lkw und
bunt das muss geklärt werden und last
not least ist wichtig dass auch die
impfpflicht jetzt endlich angegangen
wird ich glaube dass die impfpflicht auf
dauer im einfach die möglichkeit ist
langfristig rauszukommen moment kann
keiner sagen obwohl wir uns omikron also
treffen wird uns auf jeden fall wie weiß
noch keiner wie lange auch keiner was an
neuen dingen kommt so so
überraschend über nacht via micro näher
gekommen ist für alle beteiligten kann
das jederzeit wieder passieren darf
jetzt nicht hoffen es dann vorbei ist
deswegen einfach saubere impfpflicht
struktur allerdings legen wir wirklich
wert darauf dass der bund die
bundesregierung einen vorschlag gemacht
und ist nicht über parlamentarische
gruppe irgendwie stattfindet dies ist
nicht wichtig die ampel musste auch
zeigen dass die führungswillen
führungskraft und führungs mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag
alles andere würde erhebliche
verunsicherung führen wie gesagt heute
haben wir die mpk und werden versuchen
dann eine gemeinsame entsprechende
vernünftige struktur
hier an der stelle auf den weg zu
bringen ja das war also bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder ende gut
alles gut das sagte allerdings nur für
seine angeschlagene koalition in bayern
erstaunlichste satz mal wieder rolle
eigentlich vielleicht sogar erwartet der
satz er freut sich dass der rest der
republik das bayerische rezept
übernommen hat das ist richtig genau
also markus söder hat jetzt nach der
kabinettssitzung quasi im ganzen land
noch mal dokumentieren wollen so wie es
die bayern so wie er das eigentlich
schon seit drei vier wochen handhabt mit
den durchaus harten maßnahmen die es in
bayern gibt gerade ein hotspot wird es
mutmaßlich dann heute ab heute abend
wenn der korona gipfel getagt hat dann
im ganzen land aussehen dass es
zumindest das was er als hoffnung auch
formuliert hat einen zweiten satz gesagt
die omikron welle die kommt nicht wie
eine welle sagt er die combo leer wie
eine wand über deutschland und die
daraus zu erläutert er auch seine
besorgnis ab dass möglicherweise das was
heute abend beschlossen wird auf dem
koma gipfel nicht ausreicht markus söder
noch einmal ganz klar gesagt das war ein
fehler der neuen ampel bundesregierung
diese epidemische notlage abzuschaffen
und hat dafür getrommelt dass diese
epidemisch notlage doch wieder ganz
schnell zurück eingeführt wird er hat
auch ganz klar eine bundesweite lösung
gefordert er hätte aber auch im gerade
kommt die alle meldungen rein schon
jetzt handeln können das genau hat
nämlich hamburg getan kontakt
beschränkungen gelten in hamburg jetzt
schon vor weihnachten also die kontakt
beschränkungen die in diesem papier in
diesem beschlussentwurf für den corona
gipfel stehen ab dem 28 dezember wird
darin vorgeschlagen sondern sich nur
noch zehn personen treffen können
drinnen wie draußen geimpft gewesen oder
ungeimpft spielt dabei keine rolle das
ist sind die zehn personen ungeimpfte
weiterhin gültig nur zwei haushalte
hamburg zieht das schon vor ort ganz
klar die empfehlung wir machen es jetzt
schon vor weihnachten wenn wir jetzt
beobachten können markus söder soweit
nicht gegangen also auch er wird sich da
jetzt ein rein in den corona gipfel wo
die bund und länder chefs sich
absprechen und dort offenbar nicht
vorpreschen wie man es sonst von ihm
eigentlich gewohnt ist das wird jetzt
spannend hamburg setzt da einen
absoluten punkt einen neuen punkt der
debatte und deswegen muss man den corona
gipfel jetzt möglicherweise der heuten
aber da stattfindet noch mal in einem
neuen licht sehen das erste bundesland
prescht vor sagt eigentlich ab sofort
schon zu weihnachten sind beim thema
lockdown zumindest beim thema kontakt
beschränkungen für geimpfte und gerade
eben hat mir auch die breaking news dass
das rp auch sagt es soll eine maximale
kontakt beschränkung geben und zwar am
besten jetzt sofort also nicht erst
heute in einer woche am 28 dezember
sondern eigentlich sofort denen es ist
offenbar zu lange noch sieben tage
zuwarten ähnlich sieht es hamburgs
erster bürgermeister peter tschentscher
und deswegen wird es jetzt spannend sein
zu sehen was in den nächsten stunden
noch passiert und ob es möglicherweise
doch eine vorverlegung dieses termins 28
dezember über den wir gerade sprache und
der bis vor ein paar minuten eigentlich
ziemlich fest nach unseren informationen
auch in diesen beschluss vorlagen für
den heutigen gipfel stand ob diese 28
dezember wirklich bleibt oder ob ich
noch mehr bundesländer vorziehen und ob
es vielleicht nicht doch eine
entscheidung heute abend sogar gibt die
sagt wir machen das dann doch schon vor
weihnachten 28 dezember war ja durchaus
ein termine mit bedacht gewählt worden
war es war ein termin der mit bedacht
gewählt worden war man wollte unter
anderem dass die bundesbürger natürlich
noch irgendwie zusammen weihnachten
feiern können und es wird erwartet dass
diese mikrowelle oder omikron wand die
sich auftritt in deutschland für anfang
januar eigentlich kommt also da ist sie
erwartet worden bisher auch von den
experten im expertenrat sitzen so und
jetzt ist die große frage
28 dezember oder vielleicht sogar vor
weihnachten mann hatte sich bisher
entschieden für den 28 dezember das ist
das was wir hören weil dann man den
eindruck hat dass die bundesbürger die
maßnahmen kontakt beschränkungen besser
mitgehen würden wenn man jetzt vor
weihnachten schon anfängt da ist die
große sorge dass es vielleicht hin zu
silvester schon alles wieder ein
bisschen lockerer wird weil man sagt
schon wieder kontakt besteht ich halte
das nicht mehr aus und deswegen also
noch einigermaßen feiern und dann in die
kontakt beschränkung ab 28 aber das ist
jetzt muss man sagen wieder offen jetzt
neues spiel heute nachmittag